did you know vertex AI search allows you
to create search engines in which your
customers can ask follow-up questions to
their search queries multi-turn search
takes into account previous queries in
the same search session it processes and
understands human language input
identifies the intent behind a query and
returns relevant results for example
after asking what is the best time of
year to vacation in Mexico you can also
ask what is the exchange rate and what
is the average temperature in January
and receive relevant results related to
Mexico with regular search your question
what is the exchange rate wouldn't be
answerable because regular search
wouldn't know that you wanted the
Mexican exchange rate similarly a
regular search wouldn't maintain context
to give you temperatures for Mexico try
out vertex AI search today in the Google
Cloud console